Smart Bless Mead. I watched Blair Witch last night. Oh my God. Why? October Fest. Okay, I saw it when I was, I've seen it a couple times, obviously, over the many, many years. I saw it, like, as a kid in the theater, thought it was straight up real and, like, you like, shat myself with fear.
It's so funny to, like, grow up and look back at that. because they're such an improv troupe. Like, the acting is so, you know, really threads the line between naturalistic and just totally an improv troupe, you know? And, like, you can see it now as an adult. I don't know if I've ever seen it. Too scary.
Oh, let's watch it, Jen. I can't. It's not real. We can get that out of the way. Imagine watching a scary movie and thinking you might be watching actual footage of a death in the woods. You know, remember how the girl
had all the snot. I know. That's what everyone really latched on to. That was real, of course, that was real. Because she was so scared. They didn't have like a glycerin budget for sure. We all have a glycerin budget. It's like flying boogers.
I need you go. I need you go. Gabe, I was thinking of you because I know you've only seen at this point one episode of task. And that's okay. Yeah. But I'm obsessed with it. And it's also given me an opportunity to bring out back my Delco accent, which I think I'm pretty.
Delco accent. We'll get water ice. Delo County. You don't do it much. I realize. I never hear like even a jokey, Philly accent. I'm not saying you ever had that one. No, I would love to hear it on.
I have to put it on because I, you know, I outran it when I turned 19, moved to New York. said Wooder once got the look and then I became like a like a newscaster and you don't know where I'm from right oh yeah no no my brother says water my whole family says water and and I said slowly found other Philly and Delaware people who I can do the accent with and even Delaware brings it out a little bit like Delaware is almost the trapwork Delaware Delaware is huge Delaware Delaware but we should do one episode of the podcast be where accent you and I do the whole podcast in a Philly accent. I would love that.
What accent do I do? I don't know. You have like a couple hours to figure it out because we're getting started. You know what accent I'd like to have is like the one that they had on the show, The Nick? It's like, I'm old-fashioned and it was so good. Oh, that show ruled so much, just loved it. Do you still do coke injections in your penis, right? Me?
Yeah. Yeah. I don't, yeah. Otherwise, it's so sleepy. Oh, just because the FDA says it's eye medicine, it can't be penis medicine. Yeah. Get real. I have work to do.
Oh, my God. That show, it was so, did everything I needed something to do. Mm. You know, the weird stuff that they used to do that they thought was medical and then they would do it in like a big auditorium that seemed like a gym but also an amphitheater. And there would just be like the weirdest operation that was like really a dumb thing to do. and then they're all doing coke and they're having sex. Getting their nose eaten up by fucking infections. Yeah, some people missing a face.
Oh, my God. Yeah, some stuff. That was so good. Yeah, loved it. Pandem of the opera shit. For a second, I thought you were... Inside my penis. That's where the cocaine goes.
Piness, penis. Right? That's the song? Yeah. Keep inside my penis. That's all it. Christine, my penis. The needle full of drugs
Inside my cock Yeah Exactly Guys there's other This is when serious XM like Actually eats its own poison pill And is like we're done We're done
We're done We can't do any more podcasts Not even any of any of them You owe Andrew Lloyd Weber Personally 40,000 pounds From that bed These three idiots get the wheel Get them out of there
Excuse me Mr. Stern We're over We're over We're over, and that was good. We're over. Drink some water and get the heck out of your. Should I bring my I need you guys? I would love that.
Okay. Yeah. I got a text from our friend Lang, and it was like an Instagram story. What, no. No, an Instagram post. It looks like Mona Lisa Sapperstine. It was, in fact, in the scene. Your character from Parks and Rec, the character that I played, written by our friend Joe Mandy,
where Mona Lisa is saying money, please, and her father is, like, giving the money to her. But it was on the White House official Instagram. Like, this took me a second to be like, but what is this? It was on the White House official Instagram, and under the image of me as Mona Lisa saying, money please, it said illegal immigrants.
And under Henry's character, Dr. Saprstein, it said, who's giving the money, it said Democrats. And I was like, oh, my God. Like, first of all, deeply upsetting on so many levels to make that type of a cruel joke
and then also to be the person that somehow has included that and it's used for just absolutely evil means but also to be like what should I do it's not like you know Dean Kane or something like a celebrity that I don't have
the same political belief says is doing that and I can kind of if I want to decide to be like hey man because it's so scary it's the white house like to be actual white house that's psychotic you know like if you were me and obviously you're not a trump voter you don't believe in what ice is doing i think we would all agree and also i think like it wouldn't be hard to understand that that's where i'm coming from i think you know yeah um what would you do and what do you think i should do woof it's so shitty jenny i'm really sorry fucking
shitty that's like it's just like it's also like just like just humiliating that this is like the way the government does messaging is like in like weird, corny memes. Your work was taken out of context by like a completely, you know, sinister thing. Ordinary, like, nice, normal, sane people cannot jump in there every second with these cuckoos. And that was my sort of feeling to you is like, I know. you don't use your social media. I know that this has been brought to your attention. And I think there are plenty of people involved in that project who are more willing to be, like, on social media and making statements and whatever that you don't really, like, need to open the door to people who are MAGA on Instagram and like to write messages.
I'm just like, that's all that would come here. I agree. I mean, first of all, like, this is a podcast. you know like yeah oh shit Gabe this is not a play it's a podcast no oh my god you're not like this is you this is your life i'm wearing so much makeup for no reason i'm wearing a mask i made pancakes this morning to put on my makeup because i'm not very good at it yeah i got chocolate chips all over my average that's amelia
bedelia shit max is doing okay baby corn um And, Amelia Bidelia, talk about something that is, uh, it probably does not fly right now. But anyway, I, I was like, you can never do Amelia Bidelia now. You couldn't do it in this environment. You can't even do anything anymore. You can't even feed the corn a little bottle of milk called baby corn. You can't even, they'll come for you. So one thing I was thinking was like, wait, the worst thing I think is this, um, unconscious
assumption that somehow I and probably everyone has been kind of bullied into that it's like there's only one place to respond to this and you have to do it right now. Otherwise, you don't, you're not you and you don't stand for what you stand for. So you need to weirdly like get into the diarrhea pit with these monsters and fight on their turf. I have the right to like wait a sec and think about where I want to respond to this in an arena or a venue or whatever, in a discussion where it's just not immediately going to be a corrupt space. I agree with everything you're saying, which is like it shouldn't have to be your business to do it.
You shouldn't have to sing to their level, et cetera. But I do think how you feel authentically at its core, which you could quickly post and move through is just like, this sucks. It does suck. And it sucks in a bunch of different ways. It sucks for all the reasons we're saying that you're being co-opted, your arts being co-opted into cruelty and to this agenda. But also, like, people that make good art and especially funny stuff, they do care about. They're using your work as a meme because they think it's funny and effective and it communicates an emotion well and memorably.
And, like, they can't do that. And so the person who made it being like, nope, this sucks and just screencapping it and moving it on. Like, this just sucks. This is so 2011 someone's Tumblr account about how they're buying a condo and doing memes where they're like that feeling when you lock in 2% mortgage rate and then it's like a picture from the office or whatever. Like it stinks. It's so bad. It's so bad. Like I just, I don't feel that Instagram is the platform for me anymore.
I did feel like at one time. But like for me to be like honestly saying anything that is an ongoing discussion or like a. retort to something like I actually think that what I would like to do is what I'm doing which is like you know totally call me like a big like squirting douche but to like put it into my creative work which is this unfortunately this is the squirting douche this is your podcast to be like I'm I would rather place like the some very succinct truths which is like I fucking hate that I think it sucks I think those people aren't funny and that they're deeply cr rule. And I would rather put that in a discussion where also it's like, I'm not reduced down to anything. In fact, like, I'm in a three person about to become four when we have our wonderful guests. Come on. We talk about it. And we also enjoy our lives and we place difficult things in like conversations. This is actually a good, like I need you guys to include our guests with today. So when we're back to the break, we're going to get input from the
wonderful Mr. Sean Hayes. Sean Hayes. One of our dad does. He's one of our dad does. We're going to ask dad for help. So we'll be right back with Sean. I need you guys. Oh.
This is you guys. This is so exciting. You're the best. Can we just say that? You are the best. Well, great. And that's all our time. all of your time is over.
Sean, I don't know if you remember this, but we, me, you, and Gabe were working together on Q-Force in March 2020. Beautiful time in history. I don't remember this. A powerful month. But I remember right before we had to go
remote to make the show over some app called Zoom we'd never heard of, you were setting up this like mic setup, I think, in this room and you're like, I'm about to start this podcast with friends and we're setting up so we don't have to be in the same space. And I was like, what are you wasting time on this for?
Brother, we're making an animated show for Netflix. You don't need to do this. You don't need to do a podcast, buddy. You're doing fine. I know. I know. Really was. Miss Marlis was just born out of the, like you guys is like, we've been friends for 20, 25 years, something like that.
And we're just like, we can't go anywhere. So let's just do this and hang out. And they were like, oh, well, let's, instead of zooming and hanging out, let's do a podcast and hang out. Yeah. And then two people listen and then 10 and then it's like, well, a balsam shampoo, anybody? Do you remember that? Do you remember those commercials? I told they told two friends and they told two friends and so on and so.
It's an old commercial from the 1970s. Yes. It's shampoo. It's shampoo. You know what commercial from the 80s literally made me want to eat the soap and still when I think about it? Oh, I know exactly the one. What do you think it was? Mr. Bubble?
No. Iris Spring. Yeah. Iron Spring? Totally. Oh my God. Wait, why? It just seems so good.
It was good. Do you remember the commercial for gleam toothpaste? No. Do you remember gleam? And she held it upside down. She's like meagle. And there's like, no, gleam. Right?
And then she, and then she licked her lips and she's like, oh, it was so gross. But I was like, I'll try it. That's an artistic commercial. I wish there was more stuff like that where they read it wrong and then yeah, and they're more playful with how reading upside down works, which actually. doesn't reverse the letters.
Right. And we shoot it in the back of an ambulance because everything's backward. And on the front of an ambulance. Well, one thing I was going to say is, so one of the things that I think is one of the cutest things about Gabe when he was a little boy. Actually, Gabe, I thought about you yesterday because my daughter was like, why don't I take the school bus? And we live like four blocks from her school.
I was like, I don't know. I can't even explain this to right now. You're four. But you don't need to. You don't need to. Yeah. A bus is like a big car, Sean, that takes kids. kids to school, but it can be for other stuff.
I need pictures. So the bus went by, and what I remembered, which is one of my favorite stories from Gabe, is that when he was a little boy, he was on the school bus. Going down the center aisle of the school bus, and he tripped super hard and, like, fell like all the way down, and then got up and went, Super Grover! That was what I considered to be my first joke. joke. Super what?
Super Grover. He had like Grover and Sesame Street had like a super cape. Yeah.
Super Grover. And what it was was I was sitting in my seat the bus braked super hard and every other child was totally
fine but for some reason I like when flying like a rocket up the aisle landed at the front of the bus
everyone was looking at me like is he okay? I must have been like five and I had the wherewithal to be like super grover
and I that was like a real triumph for me as a comedian. Did people laugh? People laughed. Right. And I came home and I bragged about it.
And it was your first joke. And the reason why this is not just me having like an ADHD flare up ruining the entire podcast is that one of my first jokes was about a commercial that I saw on TV and I would go up to like adults for no reason and raise my hand and push my armpit out and go, raise your hand if you're sure. Sure. Oh, yeah. I remember that.
I remember that. I used to do shit like that all the time. Yeah, and I was like, everyone fucking loves me when I do that deodorant thing. I better like do this. I used to do a bit in high school
where I would have a backpack on and I would open it just enough so that when I reached to the top of the stairs, I would on purpose trip on the top of the stairs and all my books would go flying everywhere. And people would think that was the funniest thing. So I was voted senior most likely to
trip at graduation. So in the line of the 2,000 people graduating, I had people like, do it, do it. I'm like, I think I'm going to do it. So I got up there and he goes, and they're like, Sean Hayes. And the dean hands me to my diploma. And I tripped and purposed. Everybody stood up and clapped.
Oh, my God. I love it. Did you like take down the podium like when football players are practicing and they have to like run really hard into the thing? You know what I mean? Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Like they side swipe it, kind of spear it off the top of the thing is what you're thinking of.
The podium out and the principal. Yeah, I was basically the podium. Have you guys ever seen those videos where like, I think it's a thing more in the South where there's a day in like peewee football where the kids go up against their parents and they're just for tackling. It's like kind of like a tradition. Mostly moms, yeah. There are some dads.
But it's the kids are in full pads. so they're like absolutely cushioned like uh sumo at a you know climbing gym stuff they look like comically and then it's just parents exactly and the parents just themselves just smoke their kids like so it's just their kid running and they run and it just they explode but like nobody gets hurt and you just can sense the like catharsis in relief feel so good in being like the mom of a 12 year old boy, just absolutely laying him flat in the grid. Wait, that is genius. I thought, where I thought you were going was that the kids were going to do it,
that the parents were all wrapped up and the kids get to tackle the parents. You would think all the kids have it in their head that they're like, I'm going to be the one that can take my own dad down. Like I'm actually like, I do football. He's an old man. And then every single one gets smoked by the parents because they're huge, you know. Jenny, I think, I feel like we should get Sean's like. input on your conundrum this week.
I don't know if you heard some of it as you were coming in, Sean. I just heard the tail end. Here was my conundrum. It was a fresh I need you guys, meaning I asked them for help with something, which was that... Did you have your period? It's due on Saturday. Did you say I got my period?
Oh, well, yeah. Yeah, I thought you needed help with... Tampon? Like, what do you do? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. What would you guys deal? Cup? No, sorry, sorry, go ahead.
Do you have a cup? Um, yesterday the White House official Instagram, which I am not aware of, uh, weirdly don't follow, um, and I don't use my Instagram at all. It is like my Instagram still, but three years ago, I was like, I actually can't interact with this at all. It's bad for me. I know I need to have it for like, when I have a standup toe or a podcast or a book coming out where I wear a dress that someone was like, you can wear this, but you better post it if you wear it. Like that kind of thing. Whatever. Yesterday, the White House posted, um, a meme that is like Mona Lisa. Saperstein from Parks and Recreation, a show that I was on. I played Mona Lisa. And so it's me and Henry Winkler. He played my dad. And it was like my character is saying like, money please. And he's like giving her the money.
But underneath the image of me saying money please, a moving image, it said illegal immigrants being like, money please. And then under Henry, it said Democrats. And I was like, go. I sort of felt like Maurice Chevalier singing for the Nazis or whatever, but I didn't do this. Sure. Yeah.
Right, right, right, right. Anyone, anyone know what that is if they don't know my family. He's actually my 2025 most played on Apple Music. I love the movie, Gigi. That's specific concert. Well, you know what to do, which is nothing. You don't do anything. That's how you just let it go.
And I know because you feel when you're the person that the thing that is being exploited for whatever, for a missed message or whatever, and you're the kind of face of it, you can't help, but internalize how personal it makes you feel, but know that everybody on the outside understands that this is unfortunately the norm and it has nothing to do with you. You were just a pawn in their messaging,
and I think even Republicans, even Democrats, I think everybody goes, oh, it's nothing to do with Jenny or, or, or, um... Oh, for sure. Henry, right, you know, um, but... Well, Henry... But I know it's weird. No, I'm just kidding.
The nicest man in the world. The nicest. Oh, God, I love them. I love them. But what about, What do you feel about the pressure? Like, for me, I was like, oh, I shouldn't, I shouldn't respond to this, first of all, because the trap will work. Like, they have, like, a million traps to just, like, suck in anyone for attention so that we're not thinking about voting rights or whatever.
But, yeah, measles. Right. Yeah. Can you believe measles, you guys? Measles. Jesus Christ. The Marvelous Mrs. Measles. The marvelous.
Yeah. That's what Cheryl Hines. calls herself. Fuck. Damn. Yeah, that's what Cheryl. Cheryl Hines is called now.
But, you know, isn't it kind of amazing there are people in the world in this country that have A, the time to write nasty things and B,
the inclination to write nasty things. I mean, don't you have, isn't your day busy? Like, don't you have to work? Yeah. And then what does it do
for you to just write these bad things. So like, yeah, got them. And then they go on a little. I don't know. It's just, I've never, I've never written anything bad on instant, like anything about anybody. I mean, just give it. Take a sip from the fountain.
You're going to want to. Yeah. Yeah. Thirsty for more. All right. Yeah. Anyway. It's like popcorn.
You're not just having one. I always imagine they are busy, but jobs that are, I feel like there's a lot of jobs where you got a lot of jobs where you got a lot of. downtime and I feel like damn sure your boss is mean to you a customer sucks go on there we get a little endorphin hit by writing something mean anonymously like it's just it's i think sean's advice is the right to just let it this is it and let it metabolize through and outside of social media there's also like the weird like dorky second wave of like you would get like parks and rec star jenny sleep tells yeah yeah what you're
White House, you suck or whatever. It's just such a dorky next thing. It's just like everyone fucking grow up. They call me a star? I was a, I did. I didn't like five episodes. How many more were there? Because I only checked you out.
Jenny, I know the desire to, the desire is so strong to when somebody does you wrong or somebody lies about you or whatever. There is this, there is this incident in my life where this one thing happened and it got blown out of proportion and this one person completely totally just lied about me. No. And yeah, and it was, it kind of grew and grew and all you want to do is show the receipts of like, I have this email and I have this course comments and I have this that would
destroy this person's life in the sense that they would just be, have egg on their face. They're like everything you just said is completely not right. But on the advice and the great advice, of my lawyer and my publicist and friends and family, they were like, don't do anything. I'm like, yeah, but what they did was wrong. That's not right. What, that's not right to just go ahead and lie. And they're like, no, no, no, no.
And I did that. And it still kind of bothers me. Yeah. But it was the right thing to do. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You know, and I really had like raw chicken on my hands while I got the text.
Like I opened the phone with like my knuckle. I was like, my daughter loves a drumstick. I had marinated it all day. I'd never, I would have never guessed. Oh my God. She loves a drum stick. She's like freaking King Arthur. She just, I made her like these gorgeous marinated drumsticks.
Did you eat them as well? I did. And I felt great about them. So did my husband. But I had made a bisque that while we were recording our podcast actually yesterday, I guess it maybe it sat on the stove at room temp a little too long. And then I reheated it. And I mostly had that for dinner.
And, like, when I say, how do I put this, I had diarrhea all night? Sure. So to speak. Stop speaking in code. Stop speaking in code. So to speak. You know, like, translate that how you will. My husband was also ill to the point where this morning I was like, hey.
And he was like, Jenny, last night I googled. Apparently he Googled, what is heart attack? No. Because he had such bad, like, heartburn and gas. From the brisket? No, it was a bisque. It was a bisque. It was a bisque.
I, like, let it get cold. Then I reheated it. I think that was it. Because our daughter didn't have it, and she's in great health today. So anyway. You should combine them and call it a biscuit. A biscuit. Biscuit.
Oh, okay. I love this. Do that. It gives you both diarrhea and heartburn. It's a biscuit, but it's nothing like either the British or the American biscuit. Because the brisket, Biscuit is one of the bestc is one of, of our favorite um dishes there just hasn't been a name for it yet and if you're hosting a brisk you could you could you could you could have a brisk you could have a brisket where it is you
did you do a brisk then you have the brisk it new word i t brisk it yeah yeah and then we get let's brisker and then you chop off the top of the baby's penis Sean before we get to our like the audience question we get each week we haven't started yet happened no no we're not recording any of us this right okay this is a catchup so it feels natural yeah start now I wanted to ask you because you're uniquely positioned to give advice on this and we need it do you have any tips on how to let a strong and long friendship flourish while putting it on the air and professionally entangling yourself even more,
even though it is just about the friendship. Like, you guys are doing fantastic. In the same vein that I had to interpret diarrhea, I'm going to interpret your question as how do we stay friends through all of this? Is that what it is? Yeah. First of all, you don't have to talk so close to the mic, Max. Second of all, I'm kidding.
At the frat first, you're like, No, that's a good question. Well, the thing is we all live in the same city and we all hang out even when we're not doing the podcast. But we've also, we really are like brothers and just like you guys are brothers and sister. Of course we've gotten in arguments. And of course we've got it just makes you closer
and it makes you stronger and it makes your bond tighter. You know, so I wouldn't be afraid to, and I'm sure you guys aren't because you've known forever, to have heated discussions about topics you feel passionate about and you know and you get through it and on the other side
is just a closer relationship and not that we have really I can think of like one or two times that we've all kind of gotten into it and that was like decades ago who won definitely not me
yeah you're too no no no no no no but it was all it was all sibling stuff you know and then you realize oh god that was so dumb yeah Our dynamic is a little more sexual tension.
Right. But not in any of the directions you'd think. You know, Gabe and I have been staring at each other since Y2K. Yeah. Who's going to make the first move? You know, days like this when I show up in both a turtleneck and a full-length corduroy jumpsuit, you know, both of these guys are going crazy. But you guys are having a good time and you guys are going to do this forever, right?
And it's like, yeah. I mean, truly like when we got to record in person, whatever last week maybe, I was like, oh, the more we do it, the more energized I get. I could talk, I mean, I could talk all day anyway. I kind of do. Someone there. Walking around, mumbling. I know, me too.
I told my therapist, you know, that she gets a break because I just lay it all on, Scotty. Yeah. Like, I don't stop talking during the day. I'm like, what do you think? Wow, do you look at those mountains in Burbank. Do you think that like they ever had a snow cap on top of? Like, just endless. dumb shit.
Jenny doesn't have dreams because everything gets processed while she's awake. There's nothing left. That's true. That's what my therapist told me is the reason why my dreams are so boring. Like the other night I had a dream that I was taking the SATs and I was waiting for my result. The reason why it's so boring. I'm waiting for a sandwich or, you know, just stuff like that. So you dream in black space.
I just processed so much during the day that when it's time for me to go to bed, it's like my psyche can't even think of anything so it's just like S-A-T. Jenny used to fall asleep in cars pointing at herself. It was such a weird like what does that mean? Like a weird rigor mortis
but also just such like a weird like actor. I'm unplugging but I'm still here but yeah it just was fully what is that mean? I have no idea. We were in a van on the way to do an improv show somewhere in college.
It was many times but that was probably when I started screaming about it. Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah. So good. If I recline even five degrees, I'm out. No one sleeps.
Oh, really? No one falls asleep faster than me. It's crazy. If I, what about you, Max? I have to be put down like a wild horse. Yeah, you got to get shranked, right? Okay. Yeah, I'm, I'm Ambien and, you know, all sorts.
Yeah, yeah. Oh, that's good, though. It's great. Wow. Yeah. And, and you think you still need it? Ambien. you know whenever i like once a month try to take a night off and can but have like the worst night
like wake up like i just you know cross the delaware by boat um messed up i have um messed up i have um so or something self-diagnosed yeah same and so if the second i watch a movie or tv show i'm out in like two minutes oh because i have to focus on something but then if i take that nap i'm up I can watch the whole thing. But it's just like the initial or reading a book, I'm like one, one paragraph. I'm out. We should take our voicemail, right? We have an audience question.
And Sean, we would love, people ask us for, you know, advice because we're, we have everything together. Figured out. And we're sage. I was going to call and leave one, leave a message. You should. You should. Please do.
I should, yeah. Where should you point when you're sleeping? Yeah. Now you already know. That's a good one. My grandmother, Nana Connie, called the Boston Globe one time and told them they to do more more stories about that actress Jenny Slate. She really did.
And then the reporter told me. Did you say my Anaconda? What did you show? My Nana Connie, my grandmother. Oh, Nanny Connie. And they were like, is this? Because they could see the caller ID. I love that.
That's funny. And it says Jenny's Nana is what her color ID said. Okay, okay. Let's listen to this question from a listener. Hi, I just saw your post on Instagram, and here's my question. Is there any amount of nose picking that is acceptable in some kind of etiquette idea, idea of etiquette? I live in Colorado, and almost everyone here picks their nose because it is so dry, and you always have stuff going on. And then it's also an anxiety thing, and everybody's anxious.
And I would rather someone pick their nose than, like, do other bad things that come from anxiety. But when I see people really going at it or, like, cranking up their elbow, it really bugs me. And I cannot, I cannot tolerate it. And there's all kinds of things around that. Like, what do you do with what you get out of it, you know, out of your nose? Oh, yeah, what you do with what you get out of it. It's a beautiful. Put that on a month.
That's a great question. That's a great question. With what you get out of it. It feels like an inspirational saying. Or like a pillow. Yeah. But wait. So these are the high bra questions we got here.
Yeah. Well, I mean, it's a pretty easy one. That was Dostoevsky herself calling in. Yeah. I don't know that it's easy. I don't think it's easy. Okay. Wait.
What's your answer? So I realized as I was listening to this question, there is something weirdly, I think, worse about working from the outside in than working on the inside. Does that make sense? What's that? Like a little pinch in the middle. A little pinch in the middle kind of feels like you're managing.
But when you have the vaudeville hook. When you have the vaudeville hook. You can't have that. If you're working on something in the lobe, I don't even know what you call the larger. I'm like, well, that's gross. That's gross. Like the nostril, like if you're on like the side of the nostril,
picking something. Weirdly in my head, I'm like I wouldn't do that in public. wouldn't want someone to see me in my car doing that. But it is an incredible feeling once you clear that out and you can breathe. Do you ever watch videos where they pull out massive amounts of mucus from noses? No. My mouthwaters. Yeah.
It does. My mouthwaters are like, oh, God, that looks like it feels so good. The satisfaction of clearing out your nose. I mean, I've definitely seen people like going crazy on their noses in their own cars. and I understand that you know like there are people doing you know they're like popping temples and stuff because they feel that they're alone
that's fine it's your car you know don't do it when someone else is in it but when you're free when you're out in the world I really well this is interesting I think because I think it's the car thing because people feel more confident because if if somebody sees you do it
you're like fuck I don't care I'm going to drive away and never see this person again but if you do it you know in public or like in a in your house with other people watching, you're probably more discreet about it because you're stuck with that person in a room. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Of course. I don't know. What do you think about that? I have a gym membership just to pop in and absolutely rip ones in the locker room. You know, like I pay for it. And so I have a couple around the city.
And I'll just just park, get the validation, go to the locker room, absolutely get screwed up up there. And then just go. I was such a nose picker when I was little. Like, that was something I really had to like learn to like knack it off. Did you flick it or wipe it? I flicked it.
Oh yeah. Yeah, I was a flicker. And I remember having to be like, okay, this is unacceptable to other people. I still think it's normal and fine. I think I knew not to let people see me doing it. But I do think it's really satisfying and that it's okay. It's your own body.
You find a private space to do it. Like if you have like a dry bugger and getting it out, that feels great. I think the answer is you should really try to, well, this is what I would say. Try not to do it in public. Yeah. You know, just try. Just try. The etiquette is don't do it in public.
Don't do it. And definitely don't like it. Yeah. I'm sorry about Colorado's anxiety epidemic. I know it's tough to pick which brew house and pizza place to go to or whatever because there's four in every block. But you'll figure it out. I saw the clip the promo clip for I need you guys and Jenny you brought up such a funny thing about
getting your own phone or something you're like remember when you got your own phone it was such a big deal and Gabe you said and then your family would listen in or something Jenny's dad listened in yes all the time right my mom would do that too. I remember that as a kid. Like the landlines. And one time I went down to the basement and I called some gay chat group line. You know, remember those from the 1980s? Singles are waiting to party on the landline.
And you're like, oh, I'll try it. And I thought it was being real discreet. And then my mom got the, it was like $3 a minute or something. And then my mom got the phone bill. And she called it before confronting me. And she was like, what is this? And I was like, I don't know. I mean, I was like, I'm trying to call.
trying to call my friend Randy. Yeah. And I must dial the wrong number. And she was like, you dialed it five times for an hour, you know. But you could never get away with anything on a landline. No. God, no. No.
Well, before caller ID, you could definitely prank call. You could do that. Star 69 or whatever. Yeah. Oh, that's right. You could block your number. You could block your number. So you could get away with anything.
Can you do that on cell phones now? I don't know. I think so. I mean, there was a time when. I asking for a friend. Yeah, yeah. my friend Randy wants to know Randy needs to know if he can block
yeah because he likes to party on the phone jennie's phone rings with a block with a block number the number we knew about that we would call it like if we were like there was a pay phone somewhere and you could only listen to like 90 seconds before it made you paid um 1 800
red tits and what I don't know who like knew that but it's like also why is that why are not red nips Why are those, all the full titty's all red? They're all the red. The whole thing is red. The whole thing they're red.
They're bright red. They're the same, because there's no change in tone. It's just an absolute fire engine. Oh, the, I once got a $750 AOL bill because I thought I had, and my parents were like, why do we have a $750 charge? And it was because I would, we had a second line that I quietly co-opted for AOL. And, but I didn't know that the 40 free hours had run. out or whatever because we would get those discs in the mail. Yeah.
And truly it was because I would leave my computer on overnight to download like a dot jiff of like Tiffany Ambertheson, you know, like sitting on the hood of a Porsche, but it took 15 hours for like a half a megabyte file and cost my parents $800. Sorry, Mom. By the way, before we go, if you're looking for affordable plans for anything, smartless mobiles, $10 a month for 10 gigabytes. You're kidding. Thank you guys.
What a pleasure to be on your show. He's such a pro. Sean, thank you for coming on our show. It's so good to see you. I miss you. You too. I love you guys.
I love you too. Oh, come on. Thanks. Thank you so much. Thanks for you. I love this so much. We do too. We let you.
I do. Okay. Bye. Bye. What an angel. That was so fun. I love Sean Hayes. He is one of one of the greats.
I think that's the living room he or the room he was setting up in. At the beginning of a pandemic, like great bookshelf, great setup. Beautiful bookshelf. He also had a sort of a kitchen island moment too for table reads where you could see like a living room behind him. You're right. I don't know. I would suspect that you guys feel this, but like there are moments in, like, I don't feel that it's normal to be able to talk to Sean Hayes, you know, like.
I know. Yeah. Like to be like, oh, yeah. Like look into my future and be like, yeah, I guess. to talk to one of the funniest people on TV. Yes. And he knows my name and, in fact, has, like, helped me have a podcast. That just was, like, kind of blowing my mind.
And I didn't want to say it to him because I felt like I would start crying. So I'll just tag it on the end here. But it's just, like, you know, remember that, like, episode of Will and Grace where it was, like, the real share? Of course. Oh, my God. Like, I just remember being, like, he's, like, a gold medalist of comedy. Jenny, that is crazy. Okay.
I, so Daniel and I, my husband and I, we've rewatched the old Will and Grace many times over our 10-year mayor. So like, and he always makes fun of me because while we're watching it, I will mumble under my breath. Olympic level. Oh my God. Olympic level. Whenever Sean lands a joke, it's just like. It's crazy. The writing is hard to say that character is like hard to play.
And then he was doing like backflips and all this physical stuff. Absolutely crazy. Like sometimes, like the first time I went to, like, a table read for a show and was like, oh, you, like, I didn't really know what it was. Like, get what, so if you don't know, like, if you're on TV, there used to be a time. They don't really do it a lot now, but it used to be, especially on, like, a sitcom, but also animated stuff. Before they would film or record, you would all sit around, like, a table and everybody would, like, perform the script. And, like, for the executives and you would, like, really want people to laugh and, like, see if it works. And it was kind of a lot of pressure.
And it was really important. And anyway, the first time I did one, the thing I thought, and it was a successful table read, on my way out, I was like, oh, my God, the people that got to see Sean Hayes and Megan Malalley do table reads must have, like, been crying. Like, they must have, like, known that they were, like, a part of something. One story I meant to tell earlier, just to wrap it up to let you know how, where I am, as we head off into our days, is that you were talking, you mentioned. We were sadly talking about ICE. You mentioned Dean Cain, Jenny. Yeah. And a month ago, I was looking at my phone.
And I said to my wife, oh, wow, Trader Vicks is reopening in West Hollywood. And she's like, what Trader Vicks? And I, like, love, like, teaky cocktails and love kind of like L.A. divey spots. And so I started explaining to her. I was like, well, it was kind of this, like, now there's a lot of them. But it was sort of this hot spot in, like, I think the 50s, 60s. And it was like, you know, Dean Martin and his. his crew would be there.
It was sort of like, you know, Dean Martin's hang, but I accidentally said Dean Kane. So she was like, I'm excited about Trader Vicks. She's like, what's Trader Vicks? I was like, it's a sort of like teaky lounge, like where Dean Kane used to hang out. And it was kind of like Dean's crew. But I'm saying she, but she,
and to her credit was just like, oh, cool. Yeah. I would be like pretty excited about a restaurant where Dean Kane used to hang out. Yeah. Reopening, famously his crew of lounge lizards. The coolest. Yeah, the coolest. And coming up next, Dean Cain will be batching up some teaky drinks.
Riding in here on a big old lounge lizard. He's sitting on one of the big stegosaurus spikes. This was fabulous, you guys. Yeah, it really was. Gosh, I love you guys so much. And is there anything cool you're going to do before you see us all next? I'm going to send the White House some memes. Oh, we're taking our baby to a pumpkin to like a big light show at the skin.
Canso Gardens tonight, Pumpkins, Halloween. Yes. We might dress him up in his costume. Wow. Yes, you should. That's so nice. That's so nice. I'll send picks.
Wow. Bye guys. Bye. I need you girls. This show is called I Need You Guys. And it starred us, Gabe Leadman, Jenny Slate, and Max Silvestri. It's a production of Smartless Media. I Need You Guys is produced by Anne Harris, Josh Richmond, and Devin Tori, Brom.
and edited by Josh. Music is by Devin. Executive producers are the coolest people in the world, Gabe, Jenny, and Max. Executive producers for Smartless Media are Will Arnett, Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, Richard Corson, and Bernie Khaminsky. Email us at I Need You Guys Show at gmail.com with all your most perplexing etiquette questions, or even better, call us at 949-1-21-21 and leave your questions as if voicemails so we can play your adorable voices on the show. We'll see you next week, because we need you guys. We need you guys. We need you guys.
We need you guys. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.